[Music]
joining us from bambridge encounter down
its nigel good Dodds good morning to you
morning now you've said that you can't
back the prime minister's brexit deal
last week voted to find the government
in contempt of Parliament is the
confidence and supplier arrangement seen
it's still living because it feels
pretty dead to me
well as far as we are concerned we're
abiding by our side of the bargain we
entered into the confidence of supply
agreement in relation to supporting
brexit on the basis of our shared
priorities the shared priorities of the
Conservative Party and the Democratic
Unionist Party and what were they to
deliver control of our laws borders and
money for the UK and also that the UK
would leave the European Union as one
United Kingdom now if Teresa may wishes
to go down a different path from that
then she can't count on our support on
the brexit deal it is put forward
obviously and it obviously has
consequences so you know it's really a
matter for the Conservative Party our
dealings with the party not with any
particular leader or Prime Minister and
it's a matter for the Conservative Party
whether it wishes to maintain that
confidence supply agreement we're
certainly up for that so if the Prime
Minister can't or won't get more
concessions from Brussels what you're
saying is you're ready to pull the plug
on the confidence in supply arrangement
well first of all determined to do is to
defeat the government's meaningful vote
on this deal along with many many
colleagues in the conservative and
unionist party and along with many
colleagues in other parties as well
that's our that's our focus issues about
confidence and supply come after that it
really depends what happens some people
have been going about saying you know
what are the permutations what would we
do clearly if this is defeated or if the
withdrawal agreement is changed in a way
that it's satisfactory then clearly
those issues don't arise as far as any
vote of no-confidence and the government
is concerned one plan B that some people
are talking about is this that Norway
Plus idea amber rod for example remember
the
it said that she sees that as plausible
staying in the single markets and the
customs union with the EU is that
something that the DUP could swallow
well as I understand that this idea
which in my view you know quite frankly
this Norway Plus idea or Norway being in
the UAE is effectively staying in the
single market free movement taking the
rules pain in the mummy so it doesn't
fulfill the first criteria set a
criteria of of taking back control of
borders laws and money but as I
understand that even going down that
path still requires this withdrawal
agreement with the poisonous backstop in
it which everybody now even it appears
the Prime Minister doesn't like makes
you wonder why they put it in in the
first place so it it suffers from a
number of can I say very fundamental
problems going down in the route of
Norway plus the way the way forward is
for the Prime Minister to get back to
Brussels understand that this deal is
not going to get through this withdrawal
treaty should never have been agreed in
the terms that it has because it gets
all the leverage to Brussels hands over
enormous amounts of money before the
final deal is done and locks Northern
Ireland and the rest the United Kingdom
into arrangements which break up the
United Kingdom and which would cause
long-term damage to the economy and to
the Union as the Chancellor of the
Exchequer has said it's pretty clear how
pays you are to the backstop and of
course one of the fundamental objections
that your party has with it is that it
treats Northern Ireland differently to
the rest of the UK so my question is why
is it okay for Northern Ireland to be
different to the rest of the UK on
issues such as abortion on gay marriage
and yet when it comes to you know the
backstop that's something you can't
possibly diverge on well northern I was
different from the rest the United
Kingdom in many ways not just the issues
you mentioned we have a separate legal
system of a separate Lord Chief Justice
with all sorts of separate laws but
that's the evolution it was agreed as
part of the devolution settlement that
there would be certain areas in certain
large areas of policy and legislation
which Scotland Wales and Northern
Ireland could do things differently from
the rest of the United Kingdom and and
so it is but an issues like custom
and single internal market foreign
policy taxation and those issues loser
United Kingdom matters and if you start
to break up the United Kingdom on news
matters then you are creating internal
barriers within the United Kingdom
remember the Prime Minister herself said
that no British Prime Minister nevermind
Tory one could ever accept customs and
regulatory barriers within the United
Kingdom that's precisely what this deal
does it puts Northern Ireland inside the
EU customs union whilst the rest the
United Kingdom isn't and a create sauce
taking single market rules laws over
which Belfast nor London will have any
say and this will go on indefinitely
despite what the Secretary of State for
Northern Island is running around saying
the Attorney General's advice is clear
this is indefinite there is no way out
unilaterally for the United Kingdom
which is an awful position for a country
the fifth biggest economy in the world
to find itself in just to take you back
to this issue of divergence so if you
say that you know it's okay to be
different in some areas because there
develop matters why don't you choose to
devolve on things such as regulatory
checks because I understand that you're
saying that these are fundamental issues
to the United Kingdom but many people
would argue that on human rights issues
like abortion such as gay marriage and
gay rights these are also equally
fundamental issues no but they're
devolved I mean you got to understand
the devolved settlement things that are
devolved certain things are it's a
matter for the nan Island assembly and
on some of those issues there would be a
consensus Northern Ireland across the
board to take a different position from
the ID Kingdom or just a unionist
position but the reality is that on
customs
single market the internal market of the
United Kingdom once you start to create
different rules where the laws for for
Goods agri-food manufactured goods
customs are set by countries which don't
have you're interested at heart in which
politicians in Belfast and London would
have no say you're basically saying well
in those areas of law and the economy
Massa for the future our biggest market
be in the United Kingdom sorry you won't
have any say it doesn't matter who you
elect it will be for Brussels and
politicians and other countries to set
your rules and laws like an any democrat
or anyone who has the slightest
knowledge of the constitution
accept such a proposition and it's
something that the Prime Minister
herself said new British Prime Minister
could ever accept all we're asking is
that the Prime Minister bides by what
she told us by by what she said to the
House of Commons I mean the trouble with
the present deal is that she has gone
back and so many pledges and promises so
many red lines that she said have been
ditched and that's why she finds herself
now facing a tsunami of opposition from
right across the House of Commons and in
fact the irony is that when you talk
about Northern Ireland the only people
that are supporting her deal across the
United Kingdom appear to be shin feein
and nationalist and Republicans in
Northern Ireland the irony of the
situation where they're now supporting
the Tory Prime Minister against
everybody else even Jeremy Corbyn and
the nationalist parties in the United
Kingdom can you rate them Jeremy Corbyn
and if you do vote against Theresa May
as we know that you will next week and
that deal Falls really are in uncharted
territory we could see the government
collapsing we could see Jeremy Corbyn in
number 10 do you really think that troy
Micawber and the team around him pose
less of a threat to the Union than
Tereza May and the current
administration well I think you make
leaps forward which are not justified
the you know suddenly you know jeremy
corbyn's going to be in number 10 I
don't think anyone
realistically believes that this is a
scare story being put out by Theresa May
because under the terms of the fixed
term Parliament act
everybody knows even people in the
Labour Party knew that's unlikely unless
of course this still we're to go through
and I think then you know clearly
Theresa May would be in difficulties in
terms of the parliamentary arithmetic
but in terms of Jeremy Corbyn the Labour
Party he has said look you know this
deal is unacceptable for a number of
reasons and he has said that there are
good and sensible reasons why people in
Northern Ireland would be opposed to it
I welcome that you know but the fact of
the matter is we're a long way from
seeing Jeremy Corbyn take over but I
think that what is clear is that there
is a consensus right across most
sections of the House of Commons within
the Conservative Party both Ramirez and
brexit ears are coming out against this
deal because say they see that it's bad
for the United Kingdom bad for Northern
Ireland it's something that doesn't
deliver on the
result it's managed to referendum result
and it's managed to unite people who say
it doesn't satisfy Ramirez it doesn't
satisfy brexit ears and the Prime
Minister has to go back and deal with
the fundamental flaw which is the
backstop and the fact that this would
tie the United Kingdom inter
arrangements which would be indefinite
and in order to get out of them would
leave us hostage to fortune the demands
of the European Union okay and very
quickly because we are nearly out of
time have you had any conversations with
Jeremy Corbyn or the Labour team I
obviously had discussions with Kier star
mer we were very successful last weekend
forcing the government to publish the
legal advice which they tried to hide
and no wonder they tried to hide it
because it starkly revealed in terms
that what they were saying about this
pact start not being permanent simply
wasn't true so yes I discussed with
labour colleagues I haven't had any
discussions with Jeremy Corbyn or John
MacDonald but I certainly have talked to
the labour team as we talk to other
parties as well okay thank you very much
sir from a very festive looking at
County down at mr. Dodds thank you
[Music]
you